so hello everybody I'm here with deacon
Nicholas Cote are those of you follow my
channel have seen him here before we did
an interview talk about tokine and
storytelling and deacon nicholas is just
finishing up his series of books on
ravenson so we'll talk a little bit
about that but we'll mostly talk about
the situation right now he wrote a great
article for the symbolic world blog on
the question of vaccines and fairytales
and the importance of meaning and so
we'll talk about that our current
situation and see how that leads us also
to always talk about storytelling
because we can't avoid that
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so Deacon Nikolas first off I want to
congratulate you on finishing your
series of Raven son maybe you can give
us a little a little tidbit of how that
experience is then and then we can jump
into the question of vaccines and
fairytales well it's been a really
rollercoaster for me I mean not only
because of all the you know emotional
fallout as a result of coronavirus and
everything now we're pretty isolated
where we are upstate New York so it's
not touching us too much but still you
know there's always the the attraction
of social media and things that tend to
worry you but it's not just that it's
also finishing a book series that I've
been writing for thirteen years and on
and off and it turns out that's a much
more emotional and almost traumatic
experience that I expected because these
characters have become such a part of me
and of course they come out of who I am
and every single one of them is carrying
some tiny aspect of my personality yeah
as I was and I had to kill a few of them
off and you know I yeah there was one
that I killed off the next morning I was
like I can't work today I'm good morning
good morning for my character that's
awesome it's true but yeah it's been a
great it's been a great experience and
it's just the beginning I'm now really
in a good rhythm and I anticipate at
least two or three more books coming out
this year so that's awesome yeah I've
been excited to see you how productive
you been despite the coronavirus and so
and I'm really happy to see you kind of
joining our team on the symbolic world
because I love your work and I love your
thought process you know even from the
first articles you wrote on the Orthodox
art journal I like okay there's I have a
good spirit in this person so the
article you wrote for us is called why
fairy tales might be better than a
vaccine which was quite provocative so
maybe you can kind of lay out the thesis
word people could obviously check it out
and read it but we can lay it out and we
could talk about the tenets of your
article well actually it's interesting
that it all it's funny how I don't know
if coronavirus is making us more
cognizant of weird connections happening
to out our lives in different ways but
I've been preparing a podcast for for
ancient faith media and it's basically
I'll be retelling it's called in a
certain Kingdom and I'll be retelling
Slovak
tails with a little bit of analysis
attached at the end of each reading so
it's you know it's kind of performed and
things like this but my favorite part of
it is gonna be the analysis of course
with fairy tales you have to be careful
not to analyze them to death because you
can make him into a loo detected corpse
and that's no longer a fairy tale
yeah but this first article for the
symbolic world actually came directly
from the analysis of the first story
that I'll that I'll be telling which
it'll be made available very soon and
those of you who have followed me at all
will know that I have a slight love
affair with Russian philosopher of the
late 19th early 20th century named
Yvonne ilium who is a bit of a
controversial figure in some circles
there's a effectively a hit piece out
there written by a historian for the New
York Review of Books that people all the
way from here to India have read and
whenever they people who are really you
know who consider themselves people of
letters when they hear the word is words
Yvonne eg in the name you wanna diem
they automatically default to that to
that article which talks about Yvonne
alien being a fascist prototype for the
Phu teenis
takeover of Russian and the eastern
whatever which is it's a hit piece
basically the guy doesn't doesn't even
he doesn't actually quote et in the
single time he says alien said that and
then there is no quote so it's very easy
to misrepresent the kinds of things Edie
and said medium did have a short
flirtation with what fascism cuz he was
in Germany in the pre pre-war period but
a lot of the Russian emigre ended up in
Germany and unfortunately there you know
a lot of people we don't know remember
remember this fact but a lot of people
had a kind of fascist flirtation before
they really saw what was going on yeah
and it really did is really easy for us
now to judge people at the time
especially you can imagine a Russian
emigrate who had to deal with a
communist revolution who is now seeing
an Tifa and communist parties taking two
you know taking ground in Germany and
they want to resist that and so they
feel like the only solution is this new
thing that's act it's kind of appearing
on the horizon and so it's easy for us
to judge them for make
making those moves at that time when in
fact a lot of the writers you know like
Heidegger is a good example you know
where people say Oh Heidegger Heidegger
but you know as soon as you understood
what was going on in terms of the
madness you know he distanced himself
from the party but it's it's it's too
easy to judge people right at that time
I really get annoyed when people do that
and I feel like it's a common it's
almost like a weird leftist pathology
right to just accuse but we don't accuse
you know chapo sack of being a communist
member until his death basically and and
Pablo Picasso to have been gone I've
been gone to Russia and propped up the
communist state you know while it was
massacring people and sending people to
gulag so yeah I just I have no patience
for that crap me neither and I get I get
very angry emotions but what the point
is that you you can only really judge a
man by it by his own work output and if
you read the stuff that he's written on
culture especially it's really
incredible he has a little booklet that
I've translated and actually it's
available for anybody who wants to once
the buy it is called the foundations of
Christian culture and it's one of the
most unique things that I've ever read
because he talks about he talks about
one of the main responsibilities of a
Christian being not simply maintaining
an existing culture which seems to which
seems to be the default position for
about a millennium or honest but he says
that no especially in this moment and
he's writing in the middle of the 20th
century as though as the world wars are
going on he says it's time to create a
new and it doesn't mean doesn't mean get
rid of everything and start from scratch
it means look take what take what you
have good and bad transform it take what
you have now take what you have in the
past take what you expect to happen in
the future
combine it with a an active and kind of
he calls it a a spirit inspired view of
the world like he was he was very he
Galen and people kind of believed in the
indwelling of the Spirit being the the
prime movement of the of the Creator and
also immersing yourself in the
worldview and in the narrative of the
Scriptures and from that allowing
yourself to be kind of moved towards a
lifelong journey towards creating
culture through your own specific medium
whatever that might be and he even
enumerates a whole bunch of he talks
about economics talks about government
he talks about visual arts talks about
writing talks about all kinds of things
so it's from that perspective that and
from that similar kind of mindset that
he that I found this other article he
wrote it was actually speech given to a
bunch of Russians in Berlin in the in
the 30 so right before everything
started to go crazy yeah where he talks
about the spiritual meaning of fairy
tales hmm the weirdest thing you could
talk about in the mid-1930s I mean who's
gonna be talking about fairy tales right
right as the Great War is finished and
another ones about is about to happen
and it's obvious that things are not
going well I mean the Great Depression
is happening I mean who is gonna want to
talk about fairy tales and yet here he
see this is what he chooses to talk
about and you talk specifically about
Russian fairy tales to a specifically
Russian audience but especially if you
compare what he says with what Tolkien
and other not folklorists I have an
opinion but folklorist that I will not
share here but people who actually write
in the tradition of folklore they all
agree that there is something about that
way of telling stories that reaches very
very deep into the historical past of a
nation that reaches very deep into the
spiritual base of a human being that can
help reconstruct a proper relation to
the world around you in a very realistic
way as odd as that may sound because
fairy tales are what there's they're
invented funny little stories about
talking animals I mean what could
possibly be there that could help you
form a worldview and yet that's exactly
the argument that he makes which is
fascinating argument I think well one of
the things that the fairy tale does is
that it it's using a grammar which seems
very very ancient that is very very old
and it's the very fact that you can take
these stories seriously because some of
the elements are so odd in the story you
know and the fact that we are able to
listen to them
and to to think that via this is fine
like that this is this is okay to listen
to the story and to finish with a sense
of satisfaction right it means that it's
actually going very very deep in in our
psyche and very deep in the patterns of
being and it doesn't matter whether or
not they are believable in a kind of
literal istic stance or a kind of a
historical sense it doesn't mean it
doesn't matter you know they tend to
tend to hone in on the best image ins
within the narrative to make it happen
um ya know and and it's it's built on
structures of symbolism and these
structures of symbolism they tend to
persist throughout not even centuries
but millennia I mean there's some
interesting scholarship to suggest that
some fairy tales that we tell now were
first told 9,000 years ago yeah it's
pretty it's pretty insane and you're and
you're right and you touch on on
something that I think what I would even
go further I think that any sort of
realism in a fairy tale makes it dead I
think that it's it's precisely the lack
of believability on some level as long
as that lack of believability also plugs
into those symbolic structures those
commonly repeated images and ways of
relating to the world that seem to
appear in all cultures again and again
things like we talked about those with
father Andrew Stephen Dame akin the last
Emmylou podcast that I did with him it's
interesting scene in The Hobbit where
Gandalf was talking about storytelling
in the context of his little you know
limited world and he mentions the the
unexpected luck of widows sons and the
rescue of princesses now neither of
those things happens in the world of The
Hobbit or The Lord of the Rings so what
is he talking about except if you know
if you know your folklore those two
elements are tropes in fairy tales they
happen all the time yes always needs to
be rescued and by the way there's a lot
of reasons why she needs to be risky's
and oftentimes it's not because of the
princess
so it's not a feminist or non feminist
thing at all it has nothing to do with
that
well the unexpected luck of widow sons
is also a very commonly repeated trope
that it has to do with how you have to
go deep into misfortune in order to find
your fortune you have to be deprived of
everything on the superficial level to
be able to find that that sometimes mad
sometimes dangerous wisdom that will
lead you by impulse and by instinct as
opposed to by rationality something it
really we need to be paying attention to
right now no exactly
and it's it's definitely the Christian
message even though people might be
surprised to hear that is that all the
symbolism of Christianity is about
finding no light in darkness or finding
life and death you know even the
symbolism of the fish I always tried to
remind people that the symbolism of the
fish that's exactly what it is it's all
about finding these sparkly things that
are hidden in the in the depth of
darkness you know it's about finding
life in a dead in a dead world and so
that is all that is really what
Christian is about just the whole image
of the crucifixion is is about that and
how you know life comes after this this
descent into into Hades and so or our
whole aesthetic practice is a way to
mimic if you will the unfortune the
character this character that you talk
about you know that the last son or the
or the the widow's son or whatever the
the loser never done no it's never the
first time and so a lot of our aesthetic
practice is there to kind of recreate
that pattern within ourselves even even
in a world that's fine you want to
create for yourself that that opposition
so that you see your passions but then
you can also find something some
precious nugget there and this is what
what drives me what really mystifies me
about the reaction to a lot of
Christians unfortunately and I don't
know if it's a lot but it seems to be a
little based on based on what I'm coming
across with especially on social media
the reaction tool that a lot of
Christians are having to the closure of
churches and how how church closure is
being supported and and defended by even
people high up in the hierarchy as a
necessary a step towards stemming the or
what is it the flattening the curve in
things like this well I'm thinking wait
a minute whatever happened to
recapitulating the darkness that is that
is around Christ at the moment of his
crucifixion so that we can then go
down with him into Hades and come back
up it's not really recreating its
recapitulating which it's a word that
natively all it uses a lot meaning
actually re-enacting in our lives in a
way that would then allow for the grace
of God to fulfill the same thing that
happened to Christ with us but this
we're not even get being given the
chance it's it's really it's really
astounding to me how the necessity for
maintaining superficial health is more
important than leaning into as we always
have throughout throughout history how
many epidemics have we had Jonathan I
mean hundreds and hundreds are just
reading about saint st. philaret of
Mosca who was the metropolitan of moscow
the head of the russian church in the
nineteenth century who had lived through
six seven eight cholera epidemics people
cholera is much worse than than cold in
nineteen I'm sorry it's I mean if you
want to die in the worst possible way
I'm not gonna get into the details but
just look it up all right he or he he
never closed churches he opened
hospitals he sent his monastics to go
each of those hospitals to minister to
those people he kept the churches open
at all times he rang bells at odd
moments during the day in the night to
remind people of what is ultimately of
the most importance and in the kind of
superficial and pathetic and lacks
lifestyle we live in the West right now
this is the best kind of wake-up call
that we could possibly have and here the
doors are being shut in her faces as
soon as we have the opportunity to go
and recapitulate Christ's journey he is
offering it to a saying go do it suffer
with me hmm
yeah and no and they're telling snow
that's not good for you yeah and I think
that that's really in your article
that's that which you kind of suggest if
it is very powerful is the idea that the
communion we find in church and the
communion we find in common story and in
pertinent part dissipation in story is
when you say it's better than a vaccine
it means it's because what it does is it
affords us the capacity to be human and
to be there to help each other and to be
a community which is which is the actual
thing which will get us through this
crisis and not
artificial medication because them you
know and the image that we saw like the
image that we saw happening I said I
don't know if it happened everybody like
here in Quebec the scandal was the old
people's homes like it was a scandal and
so here we are all closed off on each
other no church no community no nothing
we're all shut down in our houses
watching Netflix and the old people are
abandoned in these old people home and
they died of thirst because no one is
caring for them they just died on these
beds because they're being abandoned
they just basically been abandoned and
so it worse than that it's worse than
that because in the state that I'm in in
New York there was a scandal that
started to be uncovered and then it was
just shut down of the the governor was
sending Kovac patients into rest homes
specifically into into the population
that is at the most at risk that the
ones that are gonna die and so that now
the numbers in the u.s. are clear it's
long it's almost 50% of all the deaths
attributed attributed to Cove it in the
United States I've come from nursing
homes yeah it's totally insane and so
here we are all these young people
sitting at home you know doing getting
mad at everyone else for not following
protocol all the protocol of which is
designed whether purposely or not
doesn't even matter to disconnect
community in in a world that already has
no community I mean how many people know
they're pit they're their next-door
neighbors hardly anybody yeah and this
is I will tell you this is the one of
the one of the most incredible things
about living in a rural kind of isolated
place right now in the middle of this is
because the people around me for the
most part are being very calm we talk to
each other we don't talk to each other
over across artificially imposed
services of course we're being careful
of course of course we're not trying to
infect each other on purpose goodness
goodness gracious it's not not
everything that we have here has to be
seen in black and white categories but
except most fairytales are black and
white categories but so and here so if
there's any hope in all of this it's it
seems to me like the the only way out is
the is the rebirth of small communities
in places that aren't beehives full of
or ever ant hills full of you know
unpeople going back and forth between
their unworn
and they're on home where they try to
spend as much time as possible in front
of their screen so they don't have any
communication with their unwise and
their unchilled Rijn you know did you
get Nicholas tell us if your if your
opinion on this sorry no I think it's
good I think you're right and I think
that I think that what I think that this
idea of also one of the things that's
lacking and maybe this can bring us to
the next situation is that one of the
things that is has been lacking and that
is lacking is that the destruction of
the common stories you know the the
evacuation of the fairy tales and even
not this evacuation but the subversion
of a lot of the fairy tales oh yeah yeah
with like the new kind of retellings the
modern versions of them more and more we
really do have this weird subversion of
the fairy tale and and of course
ultimately the the deconstruction of the
common Christian story which has held
the West together for you know since
since the fall of Rome basically and is
it isn't an interesting that those to
happen hand in hand that the destruction
of the Christian story cannot happen
without a subversion of the traditional
story tropes they all you know I'll tell
you like most most traditional
publishing houses that are that are
publishing fairy tale based stuff which
is usually fantasy in today's parlance
yeah are very explicit that they don't
want anything traditional and that
they're looking for as many queer
versions of of traditional storylines as
many inversions of the of the men women
roles yeah roles
yeah and notice that notice the reason
core movie that came out of Europe it's
not Hansel and Gretel it's Gretel and
Hansel so even on the level of the of
the names of characters but it has to be
the woman first now because there have
to be reparations paid and of course I
I'll be honest like occasionally I would
like to read I do like to read a twist
on something traditional especially if
that twist somehow really means some
basic aspect of reality that I know to
be true but more often than not the
twist is
point hmm and because people because
most of the people who are writing now
actively in these genres that have
traditionally spoken to the deepest held
sort of the deepest longings of the
human spirit that used to be old right
and white men and now it's young
Millennials all of whom as we have seen
as we see no but I'll in in a lot of the
political version that's going on they
have they have swallowed up a
deconstruction of reality as their
worldview yeah that is their world their
worldview is that everything is nothing
or then that thing has to be twisted and
that's it and they're and they haven't
yet internalized for whatever reason the
reality that there is actually no end to
that it's the serpent that eats its tail
yeah forever and there's no way of
coming out of it just gonna keep
spinning it spinning until you go insane
yeah and your version is going to be
eaten - yeah for whatever is left of the
old of the old world then they're gonna
come after you later because you know
you can never completely deconstruct
anyways because you know you you need
the story it still needs to have a
pattern went on likes very soon and I'm
sure some people have already said that
you know they'll say that the very
pattern of a story you know that has a
beginning and an end and an arc and a
character arc is a form of supremacy
it's a for emotion a form of power in
position on on a viewer imposing a
narrative on the person watching it and
so just in that these types of things
are you know like you said there's no
you're you think that you've reached the
bottom and then some other bigger
monster comes up to come and eat up with
isn't there like a series of memes where
like there's one thing eating another
thing eating another thing and just kind
of you know ad infinitum but you know
and this is something that all of us
with no historical with no historical
background or with no historical what's
the word I'm looking for perspective who
forgotten even though history of the
last hundred years don't even realize I
mean don't forget all of you who are you
know really happy about the recent
changes in that have to do with with the
riots and everything don't forget that
they come from extremely leftist
position you know communist one and what
happened to the Communists in Russia you
know they came to power in immediately
after the Revolution in 1918 all of them
every single one of the main people who
was involved in that in that pooch yeah
we're all killed that's right
20 years later they were all killed as
something by the way that's really
beautifully shown in him in a Russian
movie because we want to talk about
stored storytelling versions of history
not just not just you know beating
people over the head with with facts but
there's a Russian movie called burnt by
the Sun that's that was directed by and
you keep the musicals yeah I saw that
that's an amazing movie so beautiful
everybody has to watch that so powerful
and it's powerful in that sense where
that you see the general who who's you
know they come for him now and it's his
turn now and the scariest the scariest
scene in that movie is when we see that
the rising image of stallion yeah on the
on a blimp or or is it's like a hot air
balloon yeah it's coming up and it's the
hot air balloon is is covered by the
face of started and the main character
who's this young young new communist has
come to destroy the old communist he's
smoking he's thinking is kind of
conflicted about reality and he sees the
image come up his face goes dead and he
salutes to it yeah and that's it like
that is that is the end game of any such
political and cultural program it's
complete depersonalization in front of
that power that's going to arise out of
the ashes napoleon did it by the way and
we yeah we we tend to iodized Napoleon
said to say oh what a cool character he
was Napoleon was not a nice man at all
and the things he did to Europe we're
pretty bad I mean we don't read your
history for people that's definitely one
of the things that one of the problems
is that there is something about the way
that the story is told in North America
which is that we only hear one version
of the atrocities you know we hear the
the atrocities of the fascists which of
course we should because they were
horrible and we should we should
definitely know about them but we then
ignore the other side you know we don't
know about the atrocities
that you know we don't hear about the
red wave so much you know it's it's not
taught and so it's very strange I have
my theory one of the theories I think is
because there's a sin like there's a sin
in the fact that we won the world war
two then right which is we didn't win
world war two people say oh we won World
War two know you did world war two we
did we didn't win World War two we won
World War two by associating ourselves
with a murderous communist regime and
now we have to we have to hide that in
our consciousness we have to hide that
and move on thinking that we won not
knowing that we also we did win and of
course we defeated the fascists which is
great but in that new origin we gave
half of Europe to a demonic you know
murderous regime and we gave up all of
our universities and all of the
structures that raised our young people
who are now all come up as basically
neo-marxist and with who by the way
don't who have also been taught how to
tell good stories so this is part of the
scariness of what's going on right now
in the world around me is part of what's
making me kind of know what on earth and
how fasts happened what is happening
it's because they know they know the
storytelling structures they have the
symbolism they have it we lost it like
the Christians lost it because they were
there too
there were too busy arguing about the
age of the earth and about dinosaurs and
Abbas right things that that don't like
matter in terms of your actual life they
they started to see the Bible as just a
bunch of facts that were aligned next to
each other stop and saw narrative as
almost something demonic yeah that's
right like as if and you can't it's it's
funny like I I'm all for conspiracy
theories but one of the things that's
interesting to watch is how conspiracy
types they hate symbolism yeah hate
symbolism so much that every time they
see a pattern they immediately have to
attribute it to a demonic force that's
right
says it if there's a pattern it must be
someone who is manipulating and there's
no and not saying there isn't like of
course are people manipulating you know
politics from all sides but
and and you can you can really see the
end of that problem which is that they
hate narrative because they see it as
evil in itself so how do you get so what
happens is you've given up narrative to
your enemy and now they're taking it up
there love it
oh then they are there feeding some
really really impressive stories I mean
how can you pop can you argue against
this black lives matter narrative now
I'm not speaking politically about this
I'm just talking about the way that they
tell stories okay
you can't argue you cannot argue with
what they are saying because the best
you can do is come up with some sort of
facts that count to their facts but it's
not about facts it's about the emotion
that has come about as a result of this
story being told in this specific way
and the story that they're telling is a
good one even if it's not true and
whether it's true now is almost be it
beside the point because it's the net
the width and the nature of their the
way it's spoken and the entire lack of
narrative and worldview on the other
side and didn't the complete
obliviousness to the fact that no no no
wait a minute this is a clash not of
politics this is not a clash of
ideologies it's a clash of worldviews
it's a clash of symbolism it's a clash
of story
yeah and if you start seeing it on that
level only then can you start personal
having the conversation and second of
all being able to internalize and to
decide for yourself what is the actual
way of relating to us in a way that
would give your own life meaning because
people are just being erased in this you
know their own their own personality
their own stories are just being erased
in this massive monolith that is this
incredibly well told story yeah but it's
also a very simple story of a good good
guy bad guy narrative and you know and
so it's very convincing because those
stories are very powerful you know when
you have an evil other even if for some
even if it's weird because the evil
other especially in the in the BLM
narrative is that because most people
were I mean most people in America are
so white like with it it's like I think
it's it's like twenty thirty percent
African Americans and so most people
have now taken on a bad-guy narrative in
which they play the bad guy role
completely and so I don't know like
how you how do you get out of that like
do you just self destroy like you just
that's the straw that's well ha have you
seen it you've seen the flagellants I
saw the flagellants well the flagellants
and the people who are doing digital
blackface as a as an act not simple not
simply of repentance but as an act of
identity oxd like I wish I had another
identity I wish I was not who I am and
there and that is just I mean all kinds
of lights are going on in my head
because as soon as you separate identity
from the rillette the grounded reality
of who you are where you are in in terms
of you know your your family your
history and your place and your nation
then which has been happening for a long
time now but and when when it's when
it's then suddenly given this
fever-pitch
by all of the things that are happening
I mean David Brooks recently wrote a
piece in The New York Times where he
said that America is going through five
crises at the same time yeah that's
that's about right and it's just
bringing to the floor all of the madness
that has been going on inside people and
it's also showing how there most people
have no world you there's this
incredible video I think or a photo I'm
not sure I haven't seen it somebody told
me about it of somebody in in a in an
American grocery store and he walks in
and he does this grocery store doesn't
have all of the directions you know but
which way to go you know yeah which
aisle in what direction right and he
stops he walks in and he is petrified he
doesn't know what to do he has no idea
where to go he has no idea who to be
yeah because he has no identity as it
comes out that and he hasn't had an
identity at all and as soon as the
external strictures that have been
imposed which are so comforting you know
because this will control everything for
us but as soon as those things are moved
in for a second massive confusion
massive just fear and this is why more
and more than anything right now you
need story more than anything else
because that story is the only thing
that can start building you up piece by
little piece which has made the main
point of my
of my article yeah yeah and the thing is
yeah I was gonna say that there's an
interesting other video that came up
which is kind of the counterpoint to
that one which is the Karen video like
that there's a lady at the aisle who
because they asked her to wear a mass he
starts throwing all this stuff out of
her cart onto the floor just like
tossing her stuff out of the floor and
I'm like man we're losing it like
seriously people this is not this is not
going well you know just not going well
on all sides oh mercy so yeah so we need
we need good stories that's for sure so
all of you people are watching this
don't just analyze symbolism write good
stories we need we need better stories
well read them first because if you go
and start writing it right now the
likelihood is that you'll probably write
some sort of some twisted version of
something that isn't it doesn't have the
depth because you probably haven't been
formed enough because we haven't been
reading enough and because we have been
reading the right kinds of things so
that's partially what I want to do is
that we set a new podcast I'm doing for
ancient faith is is you know give people
exposure to the way people told stories
not only by by retelling the stories
that have been told for thousands of
years but also telling it through a
modern voice my own because I'm
retranslate and translating them from
from Russian to English but I'm also you
know adding my own thing I'm from
performing it for audio and so we have
we have to internalize you know the
stories that have been given to us and
if we have never had stories that have
been given to us then we need to find a
tradition that we like and build it up
because I think we've talked about this
before but it's very difficult to to
really internalize the truth of
Scripture if you don't already have a
substratum into an internal substratum
of those categories and those realities
that are put in place by good stories
mm-hmm most people that you know why did
they what did the bar was the gospel
spoken at the moment that it was it's it
was the absolute fever pitch moment of
the culture of a culture of extremely
firm fervid storytelling being spread
over the maximum amount of space at any
given moment it was the absolute perfect
time to do it because
everybody spoke the same stories
everybody knew them and everybody
everybody spoke us in the language and
everybody would understand those
categories when they were spoken about
now and speaking from an American
context there was a there was an article
that I shared about how black slaves in
America created their own storytelling
narratives by taking stories from the
scriptures and from their own pagan past
and kind of reimagining their life and
adding constellation and hope and the
possibility of reclamation through the
through that storytelling tradition and
how that eventually became things like
jazz and stuff like this you know it was
an incredibly rich way of dealing with
of a very horrifying reality and in the
comments section of the post that I
shared meaning on my Facebook page when
I shared the post I there were people
just crying out to me for the lack of
their home culture having a storytelling
tradition Americans don't really have a
native fairy tale tradition and closest
thing you might have is something like
the tall tales of the Paul Bunyan tales
or something like this but they're
fairly recent they're very culturally
specific and they don't really have that
same kind of depth as I don't think that
while the west stories are have that
they do a little bit they do but it
depends on which one's you know and and
it's and those are very difficult to to
take up right now because of all the
political issues involved and it's and
they come from a close enough historical
time period that it's not as safe as
taking some of these you know ancient
Russian fairy tales that were then we're
told from the tenth century where you
have you know the mythical King and the
mythical hero and the mythical princess
who elf of course all came from real
historical realities but there's enough
distance from it and there was enough
storytelling tradition happening over
centuries that gave it the kind of Sheen
of yeah eternality and because I wonder
like I wonder about if you look at the
epic John like the epic genre in Greece
and even though even in Persia or
earlier than that in the Babylonian
times or whatever there really was a
capacity to create complexity in the
character so right even when you read
The Iliad you know even though the story
is being told from the side of the
Greeks
it's not clear who's the who exactly is
right in this conflict right there is a
sense in which know that when Prime
meets with Achilles
it's a beautiful scene where you feel
such sympathy for Priam
you know and then even almost more than
you do with the kilise who's supposed to
be one of the heroes of the battle and
so I think that within the epic let's
say the epic genre there could be a way
to tell Wild West stories where you know
the native people aren't represented as
savages and that also the the colonizers
have it there's an ambiguity to their
action on both sides and there's a
meeting of two worlds you know that is
not gonna it's not going to go well some
places it's gonna go well there could be
ways to tell complex and powerful
stories that wouldn't be just one-sided
but could even if you'll you know
because if you look at the The Iliad for
example the Romans ended up taking the
side of the of the Trojans and they saw
themselves as being descendants of the
Trojans that so you can see how there
really is a possibility to fit within a
story told by Greeks that someone else
takes the side of the of the Trojans and
then it becomes a discussion between two
civilizations
then you have to have the capacity of
holding more than one ID in your head at
a time to be able to do that and I'm
increasingly seeing the inability to
admit to the to the possibility of there
being any complexity to any argument the
what would one of the things that has
happened as a result of Facebook and as
a result of this particular brand of
social media as it's come down to us is
that it by its very nature by the way
that it's been created by the way that
is structured it's intended to remove
new ones hmm it's supposed to give you
that immediate hit of dopamine from yeah
you know from getting a like or from
getting a great weight is the best right
of course and in with nobody talks it
some people do but what we sometimes
forget about is that the these systems
were designed with that in mind like
they were designed to do that to us
on purpose because that that's the
easiest way of distilling
the the absolute most basic needs and
ones that we have for the purposes of
advertising to those basic needs and
wants mm I mean there's some really
interesting books that have been that
have made their way out recently about
the you know the the addictive nature of
of social media and how it seems to be
it seems especially when you have these
these crises it's starting to it seems
to be eroding our ability even
intelligent people's ability people who
have you know who have education people
that I know are able took to have a
complex conversation about ideas they
don't agree with something about the
nature of this particular event at this
particular moment in that particular
medium is almost making it impossible to
have any sort of conversation in which
complexity is allowed to exist and you
know the the idea with with the Wild
West stories is a really good one but
you need to have a community of creators
and consumers of that creation who are
willing to exist in that state of
suspended complex storytelling and not
judge it and that's actually why
storytelling is so important but you do
have to break through a wall to get past
the rational self and that that initial
movement from oh no I'm not gonna listen
to your story because
it's offensive and because you're a
white manatee cuz you're telling me
things that should that you have no
right to tell me getting from that point
to oh my gosh that's a really great
story I don't care about the color of
the skin of the protagonists there used
to be a much smaller wall there right
now it's massive so there's a lot more
there's a lot more impetus on the
storyteller to be able to draw people
into that that kind of nebulous
nethersphere between between your
rational thought in your heart where
stories have the most power and that's
actually something that alien talks
about in this article that and that I
you know that I referenced repeatedly in
my or in in a symbolic world post that I
did in that he believes that the stories
are and I mean it's interesting that he
talked about fairy tales like I
mentioned already during a time of
intense ideological divide mm-hmm
fascist versus communist this is this is
like the worst right yeah what we're
recapitulating right now and yet at that
moment is like no no stories stories
stories why because if you allow
yourself to get into that that almost
somnolent rhythm of the storytelling
structures by the way all stories start
with a nonsense statement was some sort
of absurdity that shocks you out of the
reality that you live in some sort of
bizarre concatenation of circumstances
sometimes it's one of the famous pre
stories and Russia is there was this
mosaic yeah this is you know peasant man
there was another present man they came
at each other they started punching each
other until they were both bloody and
then there was a bull and somebody stuck
a it's like a sort of a knife into it
and gold came out of it and in a certain
Kingdom in a certain story so it's like
I really what on earth but disaster
you've been shocked that of the reality
out of your everyday reality and
suddenly you're like oh we're in that
part of okay I can I can deal with this
so yeah yeah and I think that that it's
been also one of the functions maybe of
that those types of stories because
they're using categories which are not
charged a lot of these stories then they
they're able to reach everybody you know
they they don't and and the danger that
we've seen for example you know we saw
some recent articles I don't know if you
saw if people were writing me in private
about this and asked me what do you
think of this what do you think
this how people were trying to say how
in token the orcs were were racist right
because the orcs were supposed to
represent black people and I thought I
mean I was like guys you this is a
dangerous this is a dangerous road to go
down the people who are accusing these
stories of doing that because is that
really what you want like because it's
not that in the story but if is if
that's what you want then that can go
both sides if that can go you can go
either way it's not a good place to go
in your discussion look Fahrenheit
Fahrenheit 451 has it right there are no
books left all books must be burned it
doesn't matter what they are doesn't
matter what they're good or bad or well
told or badly told if you're fascists or
communists all books must be destroyed
alright that's that's where it's gonna
go if you go that way and I'm not even
talking about the idiocy of that of that
argument about works being black or may
come on
give me a break but of course this only
shows how if you've lost your connection
to your nations or your people
storytelling traditions then you've lost
your perspective on everything and
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
be able to be manipulated by anybody who
has the best story or the loudest voice
in that room and you need to be able to
understand like it's so interesting one
of the so one of the things if you've
noticed the one al I've been emphasizing
a lot the idea of the margin like I
talked about that a lot because one of
the things in a way that I want to help
I feel like that's the that's the band a
that needs to be put on right is that on
the one hand you have people who are
wanting to kind of move inside and cut
off the the margin you know like that
the conservative types you would say and
then you all have people who live pretty
much exclusively in the margin and who
want the margin to basically take over
the whole system right oh I'm like we
know we need to put a band-aid there we
need to be able to help people
understand the function of marginality
its role in in the giant pattern show
some examples of it and then help
conservative types understand also that
like it's it it plays a role in the in
your story too you need that's you need
that stuff there as well
and completely get rid of it you know
it's interesting you mentioning the
margin in that context really makes me
think about something that's been going
on one of the arguments that the
traditional that some traditional
Orthodox had been giving in in support
of the closure of churches has been well
the Hermits who lived out in the desert
still had access to God's grace or are
you saying that God was not able to come
to them out out there
and like okay what you've just done is
you've taken the existence on the margin
and you're trying to make it into the
stage Center that's correct
you've you've taken it out of its proper
context because what they're doing out
there is battling demons for God's sake
that's their point there they're winning
for they're winning the war for the
entire cosmos out there as soon as you
bring that in here you're bringing the
MARTA chaos together wit with all of
that back to the center the different
markers in holy the difference between
you and the Hermit is that the Hermit is
out there fasting and fighting demons
and you're watching Netflix and the
demons are pouring in like come on let's
go I just I it's like you have no idea
what you're even saying you have no and
especially when it comes to the argument
about not having communion like all
those those permits they didn't have
communion like wait no they did they did
did you in have you how many have you
not read all those stories about angels
coming to them with communion there's a
lot of them
those are not occasional stories they
happen all the time and when those
things don't happen it's st. Mary of
Egypt
you know who's able to do these
incredible things and the one time she
protects it it's like the apotheosis of
that's right yes she takes communion one
time and she's basically in heaven right
there because she can't live anymore
let's say our whole life has been moving
up to that yeah do you live that way do
you prepare for community no you don't
yeah that's like you could say okay so
if you agree that you want it all the
churches to be closed and then that's
not having communion and how about this
you fast until you have communion how
about that that's right
told it eats three loaves in 47 years go
oh mercy yeah yeah yeah it's crazy times
it's crazy times all right so so so
before we all lose our mind here let
tell us tell us tell us before we go I
want you to give us a bit of a sense of
I mean obviously I don't want you to
spoil anything but I want you to give us
a sense of how you're closing up your
your Raven son series um you know and
and give us also a place where people
can find your books and find your
writings and obviously that book by
alien that I'll put that even in the
description you want to get the
translation that you that you did yeah
absolutely well okay so the the book is
the series this series of books was
started out with me kind of describing
his story form my own spiritual journey
so the first book first books are kind
of they're extremely symbolic but the
more the closer they got to the end the
more I saw them as a kind of an Old
Testament to another revelation a
storytelling time revelation kind of an
altar a story a kind of fairy tale
version of the Old Testament if we if we
take Tolkien's idea of the Evangelion of
the incarnation as being the
encapsulation of all stories which he
talks about in his famous essay on fairy
stories so this is this is kind of my
addition to the genre in which Lord of
the Rings exists in which this Lillian
exists in which some other stories exist
there it's loosely pre incarnational
they're not they're not peddling any
sort of religious idea it's more about
the the universal longing of humanity
for something beyond themselves in a
state and in a situation where they
can't get that in any easy way so
meaning there hasn't been any
incarnation there isn't an easy access
to to divine grace in any sort of
meaningful fashion or if it happens in
kind of odd explosions of encounter that
you can't really explain or only if you
willingly embody a path of most
resistance sometimes leading into death
so this one is all about death it's all
it's about the land of the death dead
it's about what it means to
and what it means to go through death to
come to a better life and yeah it's it's
it's like nothing I've done before and
it's probably gonna really polarize
people I think it's gonna it's gonna be
one of those books that you either love
or hate okay
I'd much prefer we're not writing those
kinds of stories anyway so so when is it
coming out is it is it out already
no no it's available for pre-order the
the e-book is available for pre-order on
Amazon by the but it's gonna be
officially available on July 7th and at
that point it'll hopefully be available
in paperback as well but at the very
least it will be available on all
retailers in eBook format yeah and you
can find more about that on my website
Nicholas Cote are calm and the the alien
book foundations of Christian culture
just look look at a look for it on
Amazon foundations of Christian culture
by Yvonne eleum or put in my name
sometimes it shows up because I'm the
translator and yeah it's it's a very
very good book it's one of these easy
reads it's not very long but you could
read it slowly for days on end trying to
understand everything that he's getting
it hmm it's more important than ever and
perhaps not surprisingly a lot of people
are buying it right now it's alright and
I'm also looking forward to seeing your
future contributions to our symbolical
blog and I was happy to see that you
also popped in on the Facebook group
people for we're kind of gauging with
you there so that's awesome I'm happy
about that no I love I love the fact
that you're doing this blog and it's you
know this past month I've been just I
wrote almost 70,000 words in a month
I've booked 5 so I needed to get it done
the symbolic world this is in the near
future for me so great great great oh
it's great to talk to you as usual and I
wish you all the best in this craziness
and we we pray to God that he can give
us wisdom in these strange times
yes indeed all right thanks Deacon
[ __ ] alright bye so hope you enjoyed
this discussion with Deacon Nikolas
Kotar make sure you check out his books
the raven sun series and his most recent
book 5 the last of the series called the
throne of the gods
also check out his are
chuckles on the symbolic world blog and
take the time to see the other great
articles which haven't written there
some on bestiaries some on cell tower
burning and even an article on Minecraft
so just a lot of wonderful stuff on the
blog and of course as you know all of
this is made possible by your support so
don't forget to go on the symbolic world
site and check out our support page
there as well to see how you can
contribute to this project of
reawakening symbolic thinking in the
world today so thanks again everybody
and I'll talk to you very soon